بعض الناس يعني تشوف اللاعب وقع 30 مليون
يجلسون يحسبون في الحاسبه كم اخذ الوكيل
الناس تق برك مبروك مبروك ا العشاء متى
انا لسه ما استلمت شي بعد سنه يمكن
اعجل رح ضفيري وكيل لاعبين او وسيط لاعبين
اللي في المجال من بدايه 2013 الى الان
يمكن 11 سنه و 10 سنوات انا يعني مشرف
ومباشر مع ال
سوبر ستار في الدوري السعودي عندي الكابتن
عبد الله العمري الكابتن عبد الله الخيبري
الكابتن امين بخاري الكابتن عبد الرحمن
غريب الكابتن خالد الغنام الكابتن ايمن
يحيى الكابتن نواف
العقيدي الكابتن عبد الله مادو ولكن
بالمجمل 45 لاعب في الدوري
السعودي شوف وكل لاعبين
يعني هي مدير اعمل اللاعبين 70% من وسط في
السعوديه ما يطبقون عمل مدير اعمال
اللاعبين ليش لان بس المهم عندهم انه توقع
عقد مع اللاعب تسوق لاخر الموسم تاخذ
عمولتك خلاص مع السلامه لا اللاعب استثمار
اللاعب تسويق اللاعب بزنس اللاعب مشاكل
كلها تشيلها عنه اللاعب بشر بسيط ولكن اي
ضغط ممكن ياثر على داخل الملعب فانت هنا
كوكيل لاعبين او مدير اعمال اللاعبين دورك
انك تطلع هذا الضغط كامل من اللاعب تكون
انت خط الامان له الاول سواء داخل الملعب
وخارج الملعب كيف تستثمر اموال اللاعبين
كيف تتقنها يعني الحمد لله لك يا رب يعني
معظم اللاعبين اللي عندنا خاصه في اخر
السنه هذه ممكن وصلنا مبالغ كبيره كبيره
كبيره الملايين في الفقات العقاريه معاهم
فعرفنا يعني كونا في شركه اف 16 كوننا قسم
للاستثمار فدخلنا 70% في العقار و 30% في
نشاطات المطاعم وال كافيات فتلقى اللاعب
يدير بزنز وكيل اعماله وهو
مرتاح المهاجم عدد الاهداف عدد
الصناعه ص عدد صناعه اللعب محور عدد
الافتكاسات كيفك اشياء كثيره هذه اما لاعب
ما يلعب 20 مباراه يجي يطلب 4 مليون مو
منطقي لاعب يل لب 30 مباراه ويروح منتخب
وعنده ارقام مميزه جدا في
الافتكاسه في الاهداف لا يستحق ارقام هذه
حد الارقام اذا كله نفس الارقام نفس
المبارات نفس نفس الميزه وهذا ياخذ مثلا 2
مليون 4 مليون في مشكله في ابو 2 مليون في
مشكله في
الوكل السهر السهر مش سهر السهر
النوم النوم المتاخر
اللاعب اللي ينام الساعه 4 الساعه 5 الفجر
ويصحى
الظهر صحيا وبدنيا يهدم يهدم اللاعب اوكي
الاكل ممكن تصير في لخبطه في الاكل ولكن
النوم السليم
للاعب يكون اللاعب يحافظ على مستواه ممكن
الى سن 37 سنه
لكن السهر النوم متاخر وتغير النوم هذا
للاعب لا ضر اللاعب
جدا
يعني ما ياخذون القرار الصح وتقا يروح
نادي اضعف من الدوري السعودي وفي
مبلغ 50% من المبلغ جا من الدور السعودي
انه ما عندها ثقافه الوكيل ولا عندها
ثقافه تامين مستقبل اللاعب وتلقى وكيله
زوجته كيف تتفاهم مع زوجته شوف اقاربه
ممكن ما يفق في كره القدم الا اذا شخص يفق
في كره القدم وعنده علاقات شوف لازم انت ت
عندك علاقات قويه جدا مع الانديه اذا ما
عندك علاقات مع الانديه ومرونه
مرونه وتفاوض فن التفاوض اجلس في بيتكم
افضل الناس يشوفون اللاعب النادي تعاقد مع
اللاعب فلان مبلغ كذا حسبون النادي يوزع
فلوس ك لا النادي والله يفصص الريال صح ما
يطلع
الريال شوف ممكن يوصل دخل الوكيل
الى 10 ملايين او خم ملايين بعد سبع سنوات
ست سنوات ترى احنا الوك السعودين حلين جدا
يمكن اخلص صفقه قيمه عمالتها مثلا 100 200
300 فلما تجي الكفاءه الماليه يكلمني نادي
يقول جدول جدول يعني اجلها لما تجي ست
شهور ما يسلمك تقعد الصيف الجاي يجي كلمك
راس النا
تكف ماسجل لعيبه وكذا وانت تقول يلا
جدولته فما فيها يعني يعني لازم تكون مرن
لازم تكون انك سلس مع الانديه مو لا انا
ابغى حقي يلا ادفع الان بعض الناس يعني
تشوف اللاعب وقع 30 مليون يجلسون يحسبون
في الحاسبه كم اخذ الوكيل نعم فعلا تكلمون
ناس تسالوني عن الاشياء هذه انت من قال
كذا يمكن كانت عملتي 4% 3% تقعد تتقاتل مع
الانديه مثلا شراء لاعب بين نادي ونادي
وتقعد انت من ديره لديره من ديره لديره
رايح جا حسابك ما اتكلم في العموله نهائيا
اليه ما اقفل الديل كامل اقفل الانتقال
بين النادي النادي واقفل طلبات اللاعب كل
شيء اخلصها بعدين اتكلم مع النادي اقول
العموله
كم تكون داعم كبير اللاعب يمكن بالغلط
دخلت الماده في الجسم منشطات ممكن تروح
المستشفى في اشياء ممنوعه اللاعب ما
يجهلها يجهلها ممكن في اشياء ترى طبيه
ممنوعه ه اللاعب يا شيخ حق الربو ممنوع
اللاعب
ا منشطات يا اخي في عندي لاعب منشطات فلد
وقفنا معه من لاخر لحظه رجع منتخب رجع من
النادي مو منشطات الناسع منشطات لا مخدرات
لا المخدرات لا مو كلها كذا لا لكن قد
يكون اللاعب تعبان وانه سح او شي ف ممكن
يطيح في الفخ احنا ص اللعيب انه ما ياخذ
اي شي الا بعلم الدكتور او
الشركه
شوف في بنود لازم عقد اللاعب لازم تقراه
كامل في احيان بعض الانديه يحطون بنود
ممكن ما تنتبه له انت كوكيل
ممكن فعلا يعني في حاله الاصابه ممكن عقد
اللاعب ولكن في طال عمرك مثلا انديه صغيره
توقع يوقع مع اللاعب لازم في بنود مهمه
تحطها تك وكيل حفظ حقوق اللاعب لعدد العدد
عدده مده العقد كم مستمر اللاعب لازم تحفظ
اللاعب من بدا توقيعه الى التوقيع تحفظ
جميع حقوقه كلاعب يعني احيانا يحط لك مثلا
النادي يحط لك بند في حال مثلا
ا غاب اللاعب مده خمس ايام او تاخر اللاعب
كذا انه يمديني نفس حقد اللاعب من طرف
واحد مشكله هذه فلا بد انك تحفظ حقوق
اللاعب من جميع الامور
تعاقديه كلمني احد الانديه قالوا احنا
اوردي اتفقنا مع نادي في المطقه الغربيه
يشتري لاعب هنا في الرياض بس اللاعب في
درجه اولى فقالوا انه ايو اسمه نبغى مبلغ
اللي في درجه اولى قال نبغى مبلغ 250 الف
ريال عشان نبيع عقد اللاعب قلنا خلاص كلمت
النادي قلت له تب خطاب نعم ان احنا نشتري
المده وخلاص اوكي كلمون النادي في الدرجه
الاولى قالوا خلاص نبغى الشيك مصدق قلت
خميس اليوم الفتره تقف الساعه 12 كيف شيك
مصدق قالوا لازم شيك مصدق كلمت النادي قلت
لهم لازم الشيك مصدق قالوا ما في خميس
اليوم كيف ش مصدق انتظرون الاحد قلت له
طيب قال لازم تجيبون فلوس كاش ولا تشوفون
صرفه يعني ما نقدر احنا تكلمت في بنك في
المطار رحنا سحبنا 250 كاش انا واللاعب
وكلمت النادي قلت خلاص ارسلوا اتفاقيه
الانتقال وعقود اللاعب ح طبعها معي الان
في المكتب وح اطلع ل استراحه النادي عشان
اخلص الموضوع قلت للاعب ما في الا اقرب
مكتبه نلحق مكتبه قال يلا نلحق اقرب مكتبه
ونطبع الاوراق والعقود انتقال
نرسلها الايميل للنادي رحت استت النادي
هناك الساعه ص 10 تم التوقيع وعلى كل شي
وقعنا على طول والله قبل الساعه 12 سجل في
نظام التمس وسجل اللاعب فهنا انت كوكيل
عندك حلول يعني لا توقف مستقبل اللعب على
شي ثانوي او شيء بسيط كده ايف
بس